c'est tout un pan de la vie de marie
brière et de jean paul deslauriers qui
voit s'écrouler sous le pic des
démolisseurs leur duplex de mirabel
riche en souvenirs va bientôt
disparaître moi suis né dans france et
mama mama met au monde arabe semble
qu'il ya de la tafna lit beaucoup
c'est ici que les deux septuagénaires
ont élevé leur fille célébrer les
occasions spéciales jean paul a lui même
agrandi le deuxième étage de l'immeuble
son frère jumeau habiter dans le
logement du bas jusqu'à ce qu'ils
reçoivent un avis d'expropriation l'été
dernier on dope aubin même sort enfin
une pensée pensée pensée ça ça coûte de
8 moore compensation au fait c'est dur
pour le moral
la ville de mirabel veut démolir leur
maison et deux autres propriétés pour
réaménager l'intersection de la rue
charles et du boulevard du curé labelle
en février la municipalité offre deux
cent soixante neuf mille dollars pour
leurs duplex et remet une avance sur
l'indemnisation définitive qui
correspond à 70 % de cette somme c'est à
dire un peu plus de 180 8000 $
c'est parfaitement légal selon la loi
sur l'expropriation
mais le couple de retraités est
incapable de trouver un nouveau chez soi
avec se monte à hybrider maison france
cinq villes du japon dans le fait qu'on
peut pas seul
localiser les offres conditionnelles à
ce qu'on ait une entente avec la ville
plus c'est sûr que ça passe pas les
maisons récent vote du jour sur le
marché donc on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés à être con sérieux devant
l'impasse la famille fait appel à un
avocat et déposé une poursuite contre la
ville je pratique depuis presque trente
quatre ans j'ai jamais vu une situation
aussi extrême que celle là selon sylvain
bélair l'offre de la municipalité est
beaucoup trop basse on voit que ça prend
425 mille quatre cent cinquante mille et
peut-être même plus pour pouvoir acheter
dans le marché actuel une propriété de
remplacement un évaluateur qui n'est pas
impliqué dans le dossier croit lui aussi
que la valeur de l'immeuble est
sous-estimé un immeuble semblables
normalement ce vin autour de 400 mille
dollars donc même si les tensions
ne serait-ce que le terrain le terrain
où déjà pratiquement la moitié
marie brière et jean paul deslauriers
pourront rester dans leurs maisons
jusqu'au 1er juillet la ville exigeait
au départ qu'il quitte la mi avril même
si les appels d'offres pour les travaux
n'ont pas encore été lancés d'ici là il
n'espère qu'une seule chose qu'on puisse
avoir un bon montant qu'on puisse
racheter un autre maison on demande rien
selon nous ce soit un chez nous encore
la ville de mirabel a accepté
d'entreprendre une démarche de
conciliation qui débutera à la fin mars
devant le tribunal administratif du
québec le couple espère qu'on pourra
trouver un terrain d'entente ici olivier
blanchard et au canada mirabel